Lauren and Alex it feels good to be in
Florida with you too thank you we have a
lot to talk about but first I want to
get into baby Ari Arielle how does it
look the smile how does this little have
a baby girl in your home now after two
boys it's a different kind of love I
can't explain it I just uh I Feel
Complete yeah and like just we have a
girl for me I think it's the same for
now I keep saying that for her it's such
a different love for me I feel like it's
when you say a different love what do
you mean try to explain it a little bit
like my boys are my boys but she's my
daughter my only daughter and I don't
know like I look at her and it just
melts she's also brand new you know the
boys are a little bigger now
yeah yeah what's been the biggest
surprise with having a girl
so far I think for me the biggest
surprise is that it's the same as the
boys I was so nervous right now right
now I have no idea I have no idea I was
very nervous that you know girl is going
to be super different and I'll feel a
little I don't know awkward or something
but changing yes but not only just in
general I thought it would be different
I'll be more gentle or something but no
she's definitely more fragile than the
boys even as babies yeah like the boys
at three and a half months boom slept
through the night
she was born a little earlier than the
yeah boys so she's working on it even
though she's three and a half months
she's basically maybe months and two
months how are they adapting to her
Asher and shy shy loves I mean they both
love her but shy Ari Ari can't be kissy
kiss like gentle nice Asher is a bull in
the china shop she gets excited he loves
everybody
so we're gonna be careful I think it's a
new toy but for him it is a new toy
hello
[Music]
what's her personality like she's all
shy I think she's just like shy first
off she's okay
she I see her like just I don't know the
way she eats the way she snuggles and
cuddles and she's fussy just like Shai
was Asher is was very different
I'm telling you if he's the one who
loves to be in front of the camera he's
the happiest baby everybody should be
that happy yeah can we see baby Ari
really
delicious oh she's sleepy
she's dressed to impressed you want it
back
[Music]
are we gonna see her birth this season
yes oh yeah okay I'm waiting to be
called in the surgery that just took
Laura and everything's prepared I gotta
take the baby out now that's the best
decision what can you tease because I
know she was she was in the NICU yeah so
what what can we expect I know Asher was
as well yes but how was it this time
around so with Asher
um he had started he was breached the
majority of my pregnancy so he was also
he was beat down so he was pushing on I
have a circlage
and he was pushing on it and I got
pregnant very quickly and our concern
was that it was gonna rip and then
there's something about the uterus
starting to rip like it was it was
ripping it was starting to rip open
there was like um when the incision
doesn't heal fully then it starts to
open up and because she has that
circlage the baby cannot come out
naturally so the baby is trying to come
out into outside of the womb and then
basically that's what happened the the
incision started opening up and if we
didn't do the surgery right away right
then the baby could have
come out to her stomach and then it's
internal bleeding and
it was not good like pregnancy after
this pregnancy I'm like holy cow I I had
generally good pregnancies you know I
was they were safe we were good they
were early but still and then this
delivery came this one changed it we and
not even like wikis you know we maybe
we'll have another baby or not we tease
it around and stuff but after this
experience and the health risks that we
found out that we actually were there
it's not even because we want or we
don't want just because of our health
We're Not Gonna probably risk it yeah
unless it's like in five years and
everything down there healed completely
and it's like yeah like I haven't
practiced that yet still it was it
wasn't scary yeah and then having her in
the NICU
worse yeah it's so hard I I'll finally
stopped crying over it but now I'm gonna
it's so hard because you first off
having Asher for six weeks is one thing
like early she came even earlier and you
the doctors were like she's really tiny
she was like
she was four pounds nine ounces four
four four four four four four four four
nine one okay whatever two little it's
under five pounds in fact she was she
was breathing that's good because Sasha
couldn't right away so tiny
is the worst and the best thing the best
thing is because if the baby is early
and the baby is getting the best care
you can't take care of the baby better
at home and also selfishly gives the
parents time to kind of recover and heal
a little bit because they're taking care
of it for you
[Music]
she came on her terms when she wanted
not listen to us like I used to talk we
both used to talk to all of the bellies
when I had it all of them all three of
them when I had them and I remember
saying please don't come today just wait
till tomorrow this was your anniversary
on our anniversary she said nope mama
so this is foreshadowing how is this
gonna work on your anniversary you're
gonna be celebrating your birthday this
is where we disagree on something what I
we used to go away every year for
anniversary it's on a holiday weekend we
always went away
the weekend before weekend afterwards
in between no we celebrate our
anniversary after okay well something
that very exciting you learned about her
gender after the birth what was that
like that was the best I that was my
idea I'm gonna put it on Alex it gets
full credit it's always fighting me on
that for a while until I finally
convinced her to wait and find out you
know at the birth and it was super super
exciting like it was he added one more
layer to the whole experience of of
birth and the whole crew in there the
doctors the nurses everybody knew how
much we wanted a girl because you know
we're kind of regulars in that hospital
so they know us right now three years
yeah no they we actually they started
the nurses were the same it was like a
party in there yeah a party
thank you
it's kind of Boogie yeah
well what was your reaction when the
doctor said it's a girl I started crying
and I said we did it
that's it we did it let me see okay
[Music]
[Applause]
yes it's a girl it's a girl baby
boy
if it was a boy would you have you know
wanted to try again for a girl no I
think so we would have yeah I think it's
a much bigger chance than we would have
had a fourth one and worked on the
fourth one pretty quick
can you imagine if I'd be talking again
saying a surprise right no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
well she's here now she's here and
looking cute
she's really cute
you make beautiful babies thank you
that's our biggest achievement so far
beautiful babies
[Music]